ce
[Musique]
soir les enfants pour ce martin prenait
lé beau soir nicolas cornichons et
juliette a en tout cas moi je n'irai pas
promené juillet tu as ce soir et
pourquoi parce qu elle se sauve patron
et que je dois la rattrape mon pauvre
nounours je n'ai pas envie qu'elle se
perdent
juilletà
je descends chez mes amis mais je le
promène ray paju l'état
hop hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
ça va être fameux camps sarrats trempe
du de la nuit tu m'as fera goûter un peu
cher cornichons génie oui une cuillère
chacun bosse moi
cornichons prépare son petit déjeuner
oui et il paraît que c'est très bon de
l'avoine des miels délais et des
palettes est maintenue ce délicieux
c'était juste pour mon dieu oui mais
c'est pour demain matin et quand on aura
mangé ça on sera très fort oui et on ira
la chasse avec un méchant et lui ils
chassent pas avec un fusil sans bien des
cas lance pierre et puis on fait pas de
mal aux trois audi c'est non on s'amuse
seulement à lancer des pierres et après
on se cale dans les airs on va faire
comme mon père gi oh
je connais pas
il l'est et tam tam tapie ne te crise
grave et qu'il s'en fait et à la chasse
est très lâche est super d qu'à
l'habitude crabit autocar à vos compères
audio
[Musique]
monta sur un arbre qu'on voit ces chiens
tout écraser la proche de tests rompre
et qui est des candidats habitude rabito
do carmo compères qui que reed soit tu
fais ce que tu dis
il se casse à la jambe et le bras ceux
de microbilles tactile le people les
centaines imminente on n'est qu'à
l'habitude krabi tout cas beau qu'on
peut recueillir 8 sera qui
prescrit
une attente à un emplâtre l'autre tenu à
chafik chraïbi hollywood à la jab et la
nina qui al'habitude y gravitent tous
crins beaucoup peuvent au mieux
[Musique]
les dames qui fait les embrasse icare
avis ça prouve que table et femmes et
nam est toujours délicat rapid hiddink
arabic autocar à vos compères du nord
[Musique]
il n'est pas malin votre guillery moi je
ne me cache jamais rien quand je monte
dans un arbre
salut je vais me coucher bonne nuit les
petits
[Musique]
enfants
au nom je ne tourne
au
[Musique]
ralenti maman dit nous nous
sommes tellement haut
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que nounours est allé
promener sa grande amie me voilà patron
au 7 juillet et à elle n'aime pas se
promener seule la pauvre est en route
bonne nuit les enfants à deux balles
oh
[Musique]
on
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]